[Musique]
cette photo j'ai une bonne tête de
vainqueur
nous étions 19e gala j'attends tout pile
20 ans quand vous avez 20 ans la scène
les frères tu avais 20 ans tableaux dont
le gamin c'est un gamin du commun et 25
ans dont 95 une photo je démarre et la
télévision donc elle doit dater de 97
ans
[Applaudissements]
jamais en une photo de vous payer à 90
noir et blanc ou non l'accord est plus
joli que moi des fermes c'est les
cheveux dégueulasse mais je dis la
vérité
dakar 6 août aps été cent fois mieux
maintenant non mais surveillez bien dans
morita sion paris-dakar en mauritanie à
nouakchott
[Applaudissements]
moi j'en ai envoyé deux une deux mois en
89 ou 90 je sais plus je suis triste
parce que je pense oui 18 51 10
[Applaudissements]
mm mais c'est quoi cette nouvelle mon
coeur et mes 16 ans sur cette photo avec
leur meilleure amie à l'époque mais nous
avons planté des lui on monte on descend
il a pas il a passé partie des worlds
apart et n'attendez world apart
non non aimé et les deux réunions
devaient déjà nouvelles poutres
alors on dans les années 90 xavier quel
âge 22 ans 22 ans a alors fait
[Applaudissements]
moi
mais là j'avais quoi bah ça suffit c'est
tout on n'a pas d'autre et salah est
folle bien ciblés la première s'il vous
plaît bas ont dû percer au niveau look
vous n'avez pas changé du tout mais
c'est vrai mais vous aime sans rigoler
c'est la m le bracelet et ouais ouais
c'est vrai mais t'es mignon non pas mal
moi ça va j'avais mon petit succès la
d'artagnan tunisois
[Musique]